كان سببا للحرب العالميه الثانيه والان
يساهم في صعود اليمين والفاشين في اوروبا
انه التضخم العدو الاكبر للبنوك المركزيه
من امريكا الى اوروبا وحتى منطقتنا منذ
عام بدا هذا المصطلح يظهر في يومياتنا
ويغيروا حياتنا فالجميع يعاني من ارتفاع
الاسعار في كل شيء لمحاربه التضخم تعمل
البنوك المركزيه حول العالم على رفع
الفوائد اذا ارتفعت الفائده يهدا كل شيء
فالفائده لها سحر عجيب في تخفيض الانفاق
والقروض ونجم الاسعار تكره البنوك
المركزيه في اوروبا وامريكا التضخم فله
تاثير مخيف في السياسه والاقتصاد والمجتمع
كان التضخم المفرط احد اسباب الحرب
العالميه الثانيه اذ قاد الكساد الكبير في
الثلاثينات وارتفاع الاسعار في البلدان
الاوروبيه بعد الحرب العالميه الاولى الى
عدم الاستقرار الاقتصادي والى الاضطرابات
السياسيه ما خلق بيئه مؤاتيه لصعود
الحركات السياسيه المتطرفه
ساعدت سياسات هذه الحركات مثل الحزب
النازي في المانيا على اندلاع الحرب اليوم
تواجه اوروبا عوده للاحزاب اليمينيه
وصعودا لليمين المتطرف في امريكا في وقت
لا تهدا المظاهرات التي تخرج بين الحين
والاخر في بريطانيا ودول اوروبيه اخرى
بعد ان صعد التضخم لمستويات لم يشهدها
العالم منذ الثمانينات متجاوزا عشرات في
المئه خلال العام الماضي ففي بريطانيا تم
تغيير ثلاث حكومات في عام واحد وفي فرنسا
تتواصل الاحتجاجات بسبب الغلاء والبطاله
ومطالبات بزياده الرواتب وفي المانيا
احتقان اجتماعي بسبب اسعار المحروقات
لذلك كان لزاما على البنوك المركزيه
التحرك لمواجهه كل ذلك ارتفعت الفوائد
بشكل سريع على مدار العام الماضي من نسب
قريبه من الصفر الى مستويات قاربت خمسه في
المئه رفعها الاحتياطي الفيدرالي في
امريكا ولاحقه بذلك بنك انجلترا والبنك
المركزي الاوروبي
[موسيقى]